Let's now expose Uman.
Let's expose UMA. R shall we? We delayed
the live stream because Utman Fib and
Chicken didn't respond.
Here you go. It's been delayed sometime
next week. Why?
Because did not respond to the email. So
here it is. Cameron made a post. A week
ago I sent Utman a message inviting him
to debate Sam Shimun on Islam. He never
responded despite claiming that's
exactly what he wants to do. So, we are
giving him one more chance to show up
next week for the debate he so
desperately wants. So, here you go. He
brought receipts. One message
foundation. So, we're going to wait for
Fatboy to show up.
Fat Boy to show up. Hey, Fat Boy.
Now I'm gonna play a clip where we're
gonna now educate this fool because I
found this on Instagram. So let's play
this.
>> This is a Bible, right? Christian Bible,
right?
>> Fact.
>> Here, for example, I'm going to show a
few verses. All right? Because I don't I
want you to be knowledgeable, right? For
there's only one God
>> and one mediator, a messenger between
God and men, the man Jesus.
>> Hush.
>> Right? So there's one God,
>> not two, not three. And that God sent a
mediator, a messenger which is Jesus
that is his messenger to mankind. Right
>> now,
>> but also the spirit inside of him.
>> I mean, everybody has a soul. Right.
>> Correct.
>> But God is unique. Now, I'm going to
show you this. Right.
>> This is the blind man who saw the
miracles of Jesus.
>> Correct.
>> He said to the blind man again, who do
you say about him because he opened your
eyes?
>> That's the argument of John 9:9. Now,
but wait, guys, pay attention.
I want you to focus. He's saying even
the blind man said, "I am." So, I'm
going to let you hear it one more time.
>> Who did this miracle? He said he is a
prophet
>> about Jesus. What did he call him?
>> A prophet, right? This is a Bible,
right? Christian Bible, right?
>> Okay. Christian Bible.
>> Here, for example, I'm going to show a
few verses. All right? Cuz I don't I
want you to be knowledgeable, right? For
there's only one God and one mediator, a
messenger between God and men, the man
Jesus,
>> right? So there's one God, not two, not
three. And that God sent a mediator, a
messenger, which is Jesus that is his
messenger to mankind. Right?
>> Now, but also the spirit inside of him.
>> I mean, everybody has a soul, right?
Correct.
>> But God is unique. Now, I'm going to
show you this. Right.
>> Watch here.
>> This is the blind man who saw the
miracles of Jesus.
>> Correct.
>> He said to the blind man again, "Who do
you say about him?" Because he opened
your eyes. Who did this miracle? He said
he is a prophet.
>> About Jesus. What did he call him?
>> Prophet.
>> A prophet. Right.
>> Okay. So, it's the argument he's a
prophet. So, not that the blind man said
I am. Okay. Let's deal with that. You
guys ready? And I'm challenge you
antarians and Muslims, come put me in my
place.
[snorts] First Timothy, what does he
quote? You ready to learn? Lord, bless
for your glory. All right.
For there is one God and one mediator
also between God and men, the man Christ
Jesus. So Christ is a man in heaven. If
you deny a man, you're denying
scripture. So if
Jesus is the one mediator before the one
God, then he cannot be God. That's the
logic. Well, let's see if that's Paul's
logic.
Ready? Does Paul conclude from the fact
that Jesus is the mediator before the
one God that means he cannot be God as
well?
Or does Paul assume that Jesus the man
is one
in essence with the one God so that
there are not two gods but one God. And
that one God isn't just the father
because the father's nature is also the
nature of the son. Let's see. Does he
define one meaning uni personal?
Or does he mean that God who is one is
not just one person because the one God
the father
has a son and a spirit that are
inseparable from him and also possess
his nature fully [snorts] and completely
with me there? Let's see. Because Paul
didn't just write 1 Timothy 2:5. What
did I say? Paul did not just write
verse 5. Paul wrote verses before and
after. Remember I said never read a
verse in isolation. Read this passage in
its context because this passage is also
used to refute communion of the saints.
Mary ain't praying for you. Mary isn't
interceding for you. So, this verse has
been used and abused by a variety of
people
for a variety of reasons. We're going to
now look at the context because if I
were to tell them what's the context, do
you know what the context is? No, they
don't know.
Now, focus and help me to help you.
Ready to learn? Okay.
The very next verse shows Jesus must be
God. Why? who gave himself as a ransom
for all
the witness for this proper time.
The fact that the man Jesus could offer
himself
his human life
as a ransom to save mankind proves he's
not a mere creature. Why? Let's read
Matthew 19:25-26.
And when the disciples heard this, they
were very astonished and said, "Then who
can be saved?" And looking at them,
Jesus said to them, "With people, this
is impossible, but with God, all things
are possible." Wait, our Lord said
humans cannot save themselves. A man
cannot save himself, let alone someone
else. That's impossible. So what is
humanly impossible only God can do.
Okay, we got it. Let's see how how deep
you how beautiful your Bible is
structured so you can see your God is
shy. Christ is God in flesh. Let's go to
the Mark in parallel. Mark 10:26-27.
And they were even more astonished
saying to him, then who can be saved?
Looking at them, Jesus said, "With
people it is impossible, but not with
God. For all things are possible with
God." So if Christ isn't God, he cannot
save himself, let alone someone else.
So if he is not God, he could not be a
ransom for himself, let alone someone
else.
But not only does Paul say Christ is the
ransom
that ensures the salvation of all
mankind, in that very context, Jesus
said it himself. Paul is simply echoing
the words of our Lord.
Mark 10:45.
For even the Son of Man did not come to
be served, but to serve and give his
life a ransom for many. Wait, the son of
man, Jesus says, I came to serve mankind
by offering my soul, my life as a ransom
to ransom and save many lives. But wait,
Jesus, didn't you just get got done
saying with humans, with people, this is
impossible? Only God can do what is
humanly impossible.
All right. What's the dilemma? Let's see
if you caught it. In the very context,
in the very context,
Paul says, "This one man, Christ Jesus,
who mediates before the one God, he gave
himself as a ransom, guaranteeing the
salvation of all men if they turned to
him."
But Paul knows the things of Jesus in
the Old Testament. He knows that our
Lord said, our Lord said
it is impossible for humans,
humans to save themselves. Only God can
do what is humanly impossible, save
anyone. But then Paul says Jesus does
what is humanly impossible.
Ransom all men. Now, how do I know that
Paul would know the words of our Lord?
You know how deep you want me to go? How
deep? You want me to prove to you that
Paul knows the teachings of Mark?
Here it is. Mark 10:26-27.
And they were even more astonished,
saying to him, "Then who can be saved?"
Looking at them, Jesus said, "With
people it is impossible, but not with
God, for all things are possible with
God." Okay? And yet in Mark and Matthew,
Matthew 20:28,
the son of man, Jesus says, "For even
the son of man did not come to be
served, but to serve and to give his
life a ransom for many." Why Jesus? And
this is found in Matthew 20:28.
Matthew records the same. You just said
a man cannot save himself, let alone
someone else. That's impossible. But
you, the son of man, a man just claimed
to do what you said was humanly
impossible.
You will ransom many lives.
How if only God can do that? Everyone
got it? Now, how do I know that Paul
knows?
How do I know that Paul knows the
sayings? And when the disciples heard
this, they were very astonished. Said,
"Then who can be saved?" And looking at
them, Jesus said to them, "With people
this is impossible, but with God all
things are possible." [clears throat]
Repeated in Mark and Luke, Matthew
20:28, "Just as the son of man did not
come to be served, but to serve and to
give his life a ransom for many."
[clears throat]
Okay. Mark 10:26 27. And they were even
more astonished, saying to him, "Then
who can be saved?" Looking at them,
Jesus said, "With people it is
impossible, but not with God. For all
things are possible with God."
All right. Same thing as in Matthew. And
like Matthew, Mark [clears throat]
10:45, for even the son of man did not
come to be served, but to serve and to
give his life ransom from any
interesting.
Does Luke record the saying?
[cough and clears throat] Luke 18:26-27.
And those who heard it said, "Then who
can be saved?" But he said the things
that are [clears throat]
rebuke Satan Lord that are impossible
with people are possible with God. Okay.
How do I know that Paul knows this
saying?
2 Timothy 4:11. Only Luke is with me.
Pick up Mark and bring him with you.
[screaming]
Paul writing to Timothy says, "Luke is
with me." And Mark is with Timothy. So
Timothy knows Luke and Mark. Luke and
Mark know each other. And Luke and Mark
follow
Paul.
[screaming]
How deep is your love? Okay. So,
[clears throat] and what does the
unanimous
Where are you going now? What does the
unanimous teaching of the early church
say? Mark wrote Mark. Luke wrote Mark.
Luke wrote Luke and Acts.
So, how do I know that Paul knows
they're teaching? Because Paul knew Luke
and Mark. Mark and Luke knew each other.
Child with Paul and Mark knew Timothy.
And Timothy knew Luke. But if you're
still not convinced that he knows their
writings, 1 Timothy 5:18,
for the scripture says, "You shall not
muzzle the ox while it's threshing."
talking about the right of laborers,
elders, teachers to receive financial
compensation.
All right. Now, this first part that he
quotes to Timothy is Deuteronomy 25:4.
You shall not muzzle the ox while it is
threshing. That's what he's quoting.
Now, Timothy would know the Old
Testament, would know that
[clears throat] Paul is quoting Moses
without mentioning Moses. But the second
citation that he calls scripture and
groups with Moses and the laborer is
worthy of his wages
is Luke 10:7. Stay in that house eating
and drinking what they give you. For the
laborer is worthy of his wages. The
Greek is identical. Do not keep moving
from house to house. Paul just quoted
our Lord's words. the Luke version of
Jesus's words recorded in Luke.
And he cites that as Jesus commanding
teachers and elders be fed for their
work, citing Luke's version, calling it
scripture, putting it on the level of
Moses.
Now, if you ask why would he quote
Luke's gospel and not Matthew?
He told you only Luke is with me.
Why would it shock you that he would
quote Luke's gospel when Luke is with
him in his imprisonment?
So if Luke is with him, that means
here's an apostle that approves of
Luke's gospel and he affirms it
scripture. And [clears throat] the
people that travel Paul already know
Luke's gospel and view it as scripture
because it's a biography of Christ
because he quotes it to Timothy in his
first letter.
Rumble, you got it?
Everyone got it?